I was hired for the one thing I've ever
been hired for that I did was on the
shield and uh whoa I like it and I and I
got I got chicken let's yeah uh and I
was humiliated I was humiliated by the
Holy Spirit well first of all
I mean this top to bottom and I like
whistle a lot I know no have I a lot
tonight no it was the first one you know
14 of the people on my Instagram don't
know how to whistle I don't know how to
whistle
really
I can do like I want you whistle I can
do
oh I don't know that one I know that one
I know this one
the loud one
I don't like my mouth I've never tried
that one
um sweet so I get hired for the shield
I have a flu wait okay let me just kind
of go back real quick I can tell you
when this was are there different kind
of farts you can do I feel like you can
do the stuff with your holes uh I can
definitely fart louder if I want to but
can you do different styles
yeah oh I know that one I've done that
one
give me another one
if I shave my [__] it claps
oh that's cool yeah congratulations big
ones big ones in the mornings and then I
go what did that [__] say
um so I get hired for the shield I'm
supposed to play a cuck
hmm I'm supposed to watch this black
dude [__] my wife whoa It's My Scene I'm
dressed in DWP yeah and so I go I get
there
and I'm not advocating for myself so
like I I just and I'm it's my first
thing I've ever done and they just put
me with the extras and then I'm like and
I'm like okay and I go do I am I gonna
need clothes and they're like no just
wear what you're wearing and then I'm
like all right dude I go I'm gonna
deduct I'm supposed to be in an outfit I
think and they're like and here's the
thing that I'm also not sharing in this
whole story and I don't think anyone
really says I've been in the scenes When
You're Nobody this the moments when
you're nobody and people treat you like
total [__] because there's a lot of
production people who are just [__]
yeah they're really not sweet people and
they're not to the extras and they're
not to the people that don't matter they
are the star but to the everyone else
and so I'm like I'm like do I can I
um can I maybe talk to somebody because
I feel like you're not the right person
to talk to and they're like sir over
here okay you'll stay here until lunch
and then we'll get you for lunch and I'm
like I'm in the wrong [__] place and
by the way I'm not feeling good I felt
sick that day so uh it was the day there
was a there was a blizzard in New York
that weekend and I was I had been at the
Borgata and I had to drive through the
blizzard to get on a flight to get home
so then
I uh I finally find someone and I go hey
I'm supposed to be like in a DWP outfit
and the guy goes oh yeah yeah you're in
the wrong [__] place takes me my
trailer
puts me in my costume but you didn't now
let's just go okay I've been sitting
with everything okay
yeah please all right you didn't then at
that point go that [__] lady treat
him like [__] I was in the [__] thing
I don't like confrontation me neither of
us do but did she apologize did she
apologize no one apologized it gets
worse Bobby it gets worse okay keep
going then so I Then I then like like
I've been there since eight in the
morning I I then get called over to set
and it's just like it's like I've been
there all [__] day
and then they're like okay so we're
gonna have you you're looking inside
this window you're watching two people
have sex
and I know the rest of the scene and
then they're gonna handcuff me walk me
to the front do you guys know this guy
black dude's gonna open the door go yeah
dudes with her
[Laughter]
and that's the scene you can find it
online yeah yeah so I so I do the scene
and I make I make a decision as an actor
this is the first thing I've ever been
casting
I make a decision to play with my dick I
figure okay and that's yeah it's okay I
know that that's not that's not cool now
but like at the time I thought if you're
cool with me I go if you're I could
one guy sucked another guy's dick on the
shield oh I could be able to play with
my Dad yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
I go up to the window yeah and I'm
looking in the window and I and I'm
looking around and they're on the camera
and I'm playing with my dick and then
the car pulls up and it's the female cop
and the dude cop and the female cop
calls cut she's like wait what he's
touching himself like and I was like oh
[__] did I miss oh no did I misread the
script like the woke actress uh I don't
know if she was woke I don't even know
her name but she got she got upset that
I was touching myself woke and then I'm
thinking I misread the [__] script I
misread the [__] script no you
improvise it it's you're right as a
[__] actor and well that's what I
thought the choice and and now that I've
acted I know that you're allowed to do
some wild [__] as an actor yeah yeah I'm
like I'm like my first thing so I'm like
oh [__] so they come over they pull her
so they go okay we're sorry we'll talk
to him Michael Chiclets in the I think
was directing this episode but there's
another guy
so they take her back to the car they
put him in position one and Michael
checklist goes
I love your choice
I love it ignore her here's what we're
going to do we're going to shoot a bunch
of close-ups of you playing with your
dick
we're gonna like do like some long lens
[__] yeah give us some time but we're
gonna but really go out [__] yeah really
go after it and then and then when
you're done when we bring her back in
just don't play with your dick okay okay
very good because we'll have it covered
we'll use that but don't play with your
dick when she pulls up I want deal so I
feel Vindicated
so like all right she's on position one
action so I like go over look at the
window and I start playing with my dick
I'm like I'm like oh nice
and then it's like I'm like okay this
has been like 10 seconds yeah and then
I'm like now I'm on a minute I'm like
I'm still putting my dick getting hard
and I'm like oh my God so now I'm like
it's getting hard I'm really getting
into it yeah you got my dick more like
[__] three minutes in I'm like is he
gonna wait until I come like
we should have it by now right and then
in my head Michael checklist has just
said the director of his chair going
let's see how long this guy will go
yeah with the camera on yeah I guess
okay okay I haven't seen I haven't seen
the scene in a long time I know I think
they show me playing with my dick a
little bit and then we did the scene
okay so that's me
yeah okay yeah I'm playing with my dick
hang on pal look at that okay you were
dude that's how quick it was
just now
I'll just go hold on turn around hands
behind your back oh I I have permission
hands behind your back
yeah you're good actor dude thank you
sorry to bother you sir we just
apprehended a man looking through your
window yo girl
it's all good
dude with huh
[Laughter]
do you know this man married to him long
enough he's your husband I told you look
no one's breaking the law here officer
we're just playing right role playing on
the way to work with our
friend
it's kind of sad it's a Saturday and by
the way I didn't even have to read for
it I just walked in and they're like
it's him
really they're like I didn't even hear
the cut I didn't even read for it I
didn't even [__] you I walked in I had
the Cena they're like no no we got it
it's him and I was like oh cool you like
to watch black guys [__] your wife and I
was like okay
so you don't want me to read it like I
couldn't that's different dude I mean
for the little I saw you I go that's
he's good
yeah and did you do other acting after
that or no no that really depressed me
that whole experience really kind of
like shook me and then I did I did uh I
did a pilot for CBS that was really fun
yeah but I was I